This is the Chris Abraham Show.
It's The Chris Abraham Show
season five, episode 54.
So here's a cultural rift that I
feel like, quote UN quote white
people can't really deal with is
the fact that, like, it's a
cultural thing, that people just
play their phones on speaker or
publicly run their music.
Through their Bluetooth speakers
and public places such as the
beach and the park, in
courtyards and bus stops and
stuff like that.
And in kind of a traditional
community all the way going back
to boom boxes and and anytime
you had portable radios
including transistor radios,
playing those things out loud
and not quietly and not.
Through in earbud is considered
extremely antisocial.
It's considered to be hostile
and in general people will call
cops based on that, right?
They will call cops.
And you could plot it all over
YouTube, like if you play your
boom box in the bus, someone's
going to yell at you.
And it's generally a Karen and I
personally say gets aggressive
and it's antisocial and it's.
It's rude.
Extremely rude.
Like, actively rude.
Like it feels like you're
intentionally messing with my
world.
But I know it's not that at all.
So I always make sure that I
have in the head earphones and
so none of that bothers me.
And now that I have, if you will
know that I have Adobe sound
cancelling, it doesn't bother my
podcasts at all either.
Not anymore.
Good morning.
As I was walking down my own
hallway, a broad shouldered and
some young Latino man was
playing Latin music from his
cell phone just like out loud in
the speaker.
And so that's just brought that
to my mind.
Doesn't bother me per se, but I
do realize that it it it really
like perks up my autonomics
autonomic system.
Which is to say, I feel I feel
defensively aggressive, like
based on the hostile nature of
Public Music playing via
Bluetooth or the speaker on a
phone.
I feel like I am.
My autonomic response is that
I'm going to get in a in a fist
fight soon, so it sets my, you
know, autonomic system on edge,
ready for a fight because.
Any kind of antisocial
aggressive choice is dealing
with kind of an autonomic
response.
And 0% of the time is the music
that the people choose to play
on the beach or in the park or
whatever. 0% of the time, is it
music that I want to listen to?
Unless it's NPR.
If it's if they're playing WAMU
on the speaker, that's fine.
So anyway, I was not going to be
talking about this today, but.
That's what happens.
I did ooh, I have my hats in my
bag.
Yay, thought I forgot my hats or
my hat and my glasses, but I had
packed them in my bag yesterday.
So I'm good.
I'm good to go.
No turning back.
All right.
So aside from that comment that
I'm going to make, which is also
related to 1000 articles over
the last five years where where
people of color with spicier
cultures.
Move into, I mean, I guess they
either become, hey, how's it
going?
They either become upwardly
mobile and move into a
traditionally kind of Protestant
Waspy neighborhood or a bunch of
Waspy neighbors gentrify that
particular neighborhood and
before nice truck.
It's what it's beautiful, Yeah.
Looks like it wants to be in
Baja though.
Have a good day.
So, So yeah, so there's always
these interactions and in in
transitioning neighborhoods
where, oh, recently there was a
lot of articles about this
happening at universities where
you know in this case it was, it
was either code switch or it
was.
Those awesome like Asta la
Proxima that that talk show that
radio show about Latin Americans
in Hawaii, I mean in America
called Latino USAI think.
And it's really.
I love that show.
It's always on the off hours I
never get to hear it.
But it's so awesome and this was
a report put by a girl who moved
into whatever Princeton dorm or
whatever.
And.
She and all of her Latina
friends were like having get
togethers.
They were laughing, they were
goofing around, they were
playing music, they were
dancing, they were filling all
the other awesome Latina
stereotypes.
And like, they were like the
white kids were freaking the
fuck out.
The white kids were freaking the
And they were like, you can't
behave like this in the dorms.
Dorms are study areas, Dorms
are.
Not party areas, you know, you
have roommates and your
roommates expect to be able to
study and so forth.
And like, I didn't have a
culture of going to the gym, I'm
going to the library.
When I was a a kid, either in
high school or in college, I
wish I had.
I wish someone had.
Sat me down is like, don't
expect your room to be a
monastic cell.
If you need to study, go to the
library.
But there's a real cultural
conflict.
Between like like traditionally
like studious nerd nerdotypes
who, you know really want the
dorm to be a an academic,
respectful place, and this
belief that you know or whatever
awful type of terrible
stereotype you want to, you
know, it's sort of a an
environment of My Big Fat Greek
Wedding.
Archetypes, you know, where
there's the nerdy only child,
Waspy, New England husband whose
parents are the only people at
the wedding from his side
because the parents really don't
have that much, don't really
have that much of a relationship
with their.
You know, it's very much an
insular mom, dad, son type of
experience like mine was.
Although, yeah, I'm a.
I totally don't think about it
this way, but I'm totally from a
broken marriage, right?
Like my parents separated when I
was 13.
So like, I don't even think
about it that way.
Like my dad didn't move to a
different state and a while he
didn't participate a lot.
Like, I saw enough of him.
But yeah, divorce, child of
divorce.
I don't identify with being that
that's really weird.
But anyway, versus the the Greek
woman bride fiance.
Who's everybody's and everybody
else's business.
Everybody's getting together.
Loudness is a way of showing,
like, love languages.
Loudness, Love languages is
fetching love languages.
There's a diesel truck going.
Room, room, room, room, room,
room.
Here's an evil truck going all
day long.
All right, so there's that
thing, right?
Like so.
I mean it's.
It's a commonplace thing.
Like, even at my Penrose Square
Park, there's always these like,
dudes who have these electric
mobility vehicles and they're
like two or three, three or four
wheels.
The wheels on the truck go round
and round and they always have
like like big big what are they
called?
Big portable radios or or
Bluetooth speakers?
Big ones like.
Ghetto blasters, as they used to
be called, there and they're
playing their music down the
street.
Or there's like the kind of guy
on his bicycle and he's got like
a Bluetooth speaker blaring on
his on his bicycle hanging from
a carabiner.
Or there's like this isn't only
a a people of color thing either
like they totally build.
It's a it's a Harley-Davidson
owner.
Like it's an aggressive
antisocial.
Loud pipes like loud speakers on
a Harley-Davidson blasting away
like you know, classic rock loud
enough that it overwhelms the
loud pipes on the
Harley-Davidson.
And all these things kind of go
together into a really world
blowing experience of of what
seems.
Capital a antisocial and
antisocial behavior tends to
result in in in escalation and
there's never been a speaker.
Well, I think they're probably
are speakers on on the big
touring bikes, on the big BMW
touring bikes.
But once you realize that
helmets can have a little
Bluetooth speakers in them, and
even before that, all the way
back to Walkman days like
they've got in ear buds.
That people like used to both
block out motorcycle and wind
noise, but also play tapes and
CD's at those times and radio
and now Bluetooth and streaming
and stuff.
Like, once you have access to
that, it seems extremely
aggressive and countercultural
in a hostile way to be blasting.
And and this is, you know, in a
similar way, people perceive
this kind of thing in the world
of me, you know, recording these
podcasts in public, screaming at
the top of my lungs over a
street, street construction, or,
you know, when people take loud
calls or loud conferences or
whatever and like the DMV or in
the cafe or in a line at a
theater or whatever and talk not
in quiet, hushed tones.
But talk loud as fuck.
And and so, like, it's not an
inconsistent thing.
The topic of today, while the
topic of today is now about how
aggressive and antisocial
playing your music on a
Bluetooth speaker at the beach,
at a park, in the apartment, in
the elevator.
It's the same kind of thing, you
know, when you there's a lot of
people, a lot of migrants and
immigrants, who really miss
their families.
And so they've got a constant
stream all the way from home.
It's like a portal to to to to
Kabul, and it's always on
speaker.
And like they're basically
having the conversations that my
family could only afford to have
10 minutes once a week back in
the 70s into this constant
running live stream.
Sort of like a live Twitch kind
of stream where, you know, they
just.
Live with their extended family
who are abroad.
And most people I think, kind of
put it in their ear.
Most people are in love with
their iPods or whatever, not
iPods, I ear Pods or whatever
they're called.
But you know, it's still a thing
like and I I don't think I would
notice that if I didn't live in
such a immigrant, migrant,
refugee building.
So the topic is going to be the
next.
The next episode is going to be
the fact that I had this
conversation with my best friend
Mark and I asked to be read in
since he's super, like
intellectual, cultural,
entrepreneurial, Silicon Valley
tech elite.
I told him to read me in on this
whole climate change thing and
he said it's all true.
But then he also said that that
in order to make people, you
know, aggressively.
Comply.
You got to, like, spook them and
lie to them and nudge them and
and and manipulate them and
scare them and put them into a
place where they're convinced
the only people don't care about
a threat that happens a month
from now or a year from now.
And they certainly don't care
about a threat that's five or 10
years from now, certainly not 30
years from now and.
Nothing's really going to happen
for another 30 years.
So we need to make, we need to
nudge people in a a way that
makes them feel like there's an
existential crisis that
supersedes their next paycheck,
right.
So they need to feel that if
they don't make decisions based
on elections, based on polls,
based on, you know, general
discussions like if we meaning.
The powers that be, if we can
scare them into compliance and
they don't comply themselves,
then we're eventually going to
have to force them into
compliance, which is even harder
and more expensive.
And you know, now I'm riffing
here.
Mark did not say any of these
things, but basically the whole
nudge culture that Britain is
admitted to says that we tell
you what you need to hear in
order to comply with our larger
purpose.
We manipulate you for your own
good.
We nudge you for your own good.
We push you in the right
direction, using a certain level
of deceit, so that in the long
run you will have done something
on behalf of not only your
goodness, your health, but the
health of everybody around you.
We are willing to tell you bald
face lies so as to motivate you.
To decide on your own in an opt
in way to make drastic cultural,
financial, fiscal, educational,
environmental, political,
cultural changes that are
drastic and in many ways
antithetical to your enjoyment,
to your normal, to the way you
spend your money, to the way you
feed yourself.
To your daily life experience,
to your relationship with your
parents, your children, your
greater family.
Different relationship with your
community, different
relationship with the things you
own and the things you wear and
the things you eat and the
things you drink.
And so this Cultural Revolution
is trying the nudge technique.
But unfortunately, we live in a
world where there's so much
viable counter messaging that
people can do really simple
checks and balances and then
completely counter message
against the bald face lies that
they can find all kinds of
receipts in the wallets of the
person who's trying to nudge
you.
That doesn't that.
That is hypocritical or
antithetical to the stories
being told, you know?
Every leader has a house on the
beach.
Everybody can get a mortgage.
People haven't been abandoning
shorefront places like people
still fly their private planes.
People still own their
Lamborghinis.
Nobody sold their 30,000 square
foot house.
Nobody sold their second 30,000
square foot house, or their
third 30,000 square foot house,
or their 10,000 square foot
cabin.
Nobody's got rid of their
helicopter.
Nobody has divested themselves
from their investments.
Nobody has given up their steak
dinners.
Very few people eat bugs anyway.
So when you when you, when you
have counter messaging, there's
always been counter messaging.
But we've called those crack
pots, right?
But now the crack pots have an
extreme amount of influence and
everything.
Every time there's a nudge,
which is done for allegedly the
good of all humanity around the
world.
Every Neolib proactive war.
Every blowing up of a of a of a
gas pipeline.
Every change of uranium mining
area into national parks, Every
this and every that, Every
aggressive move against.
Traditional government
structures the everything is an
attempt to try to manipulate a
mob who needs to steer and run
themselves because it's
impossible to have a one to one
physical like control
methodology, even with a I or
whatever at the end of the day
like.
It's not working And there's
what is it called?
What is the term?
The term for it is there's a
lower return.
There's like diminishing
returns, the law of diminishing
return site.
Obviously the more people catch
that what they read in the Bible
and what they're told about the
Bible, what they read in a in a
science paper and what you tell
them is in a science paper, what
they see reported from local
news.
Anchors and the local telegram
reports and and local tick
tockers and what the news
reports is, is happening.
Eventually these get so out of
whack that people start
completely distrusting and
rejecting the official narrative
in which the the nudging, the
manipulation, and the telling
you little lies for your own
good.
Starts breaking down and people
like, do not trust you anymore
and they start to aggressively
not trust you.
And it becomes an antitrust kind
of thing, not the legal, but it
becomes the opposite of trust.
People never believe anything
you say, and you've completely
been discredited and nothing you
say has any effect.
And in fact, anything you try to
say results in extreme blowback.
So.
Who knows what happens then,
right?
So anyway, tomorrow.
Oh, well, then I we talked about
it.
I'll talk about it more if
you're interested in, but this
is going to be a controversial
episode that nobody is going to
listen to and nobody will give a
shit about it.
So this was episode 54, season
five of The Chris Abraham Show.
My name is Chris Abraham.
Please, like, subscribe and
click the notification bell and
share with your friends.
I'll talk to you soon.
Love you.
Bye.
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time.
Now.